[Music]
fiance broke the Instagram record for
most the likes with her announcement
that she is having twins so the big
question now is when and how well mama B
make her first public appearance since
she dropped the happy news multiple
sources telling T that Beyonce will
perform a week from Sunday at the
Grammys she was spotting today at a
secret rehearsal in Los Angeles prepping
for the show with a glam squad camera
crew and her team of dancers Beyonce
fans however are concerned today that
singer will drop out of the Coachella
Music Festival it's in April so if
beyonce is three months pregnant she
would be at five and a half months along
been mean Walt beyoncé released new
photos today and this is not your
typical pregnancy announcement that is
Beyonce pregnant with twins under water
on top of red Porsche and with her
firstborn Blue Ivy the images are also
layered with symbols and perhaps hidden
meaning there's speculation that beyonce
is hinting hear that she's having a boy
and a girl the singer wore a small pink
ribbon and mismatched blue panties this
image appears to be inspired by
Botticelli's painting The Birth of Venus
and that's a statue of Nefertiti the
queen of Egypt and then there's this
Instagram post from back in December at
the time everyone thought the on SE was
simply flashing a peace sign but now it
sure seems like a secret message from be
two babies fiancée also used her photo
download to shut down the haters somehow
falsely claims that Beyonce faked her
last pregnancy and used a surrogate
there are actually a lot of people that
believe this rumor well be appeared to
address it again posting her own phone
was off her pregnancy progression with
blue ivy
you